>>Teacher: All right.
Okay, guys, heads up.
>>Narrator: Something
big is taking off
at high schools all over California.
>>Alan: If it wasn't for the Academy,
I- I probably would've dropped out,
and, you know, I'm graduating
now and gonna go to college.
>>Narrator: More than 1,000 schools
within schools are merging
college prep and career
and technical education, making
the high school experience real,
rigorous, and rewarding.
>>Teacher: I know it's going
to be a thicker viscosity.
>>Steven: This is about making
sure that the young people of today
in California and across the
country are prepared to go
on to higher education, go into the
world of work, and be successful
because the skill sets that they're
getting really are 21st century.
>>Teacher: The average velocity
is- that was your velocity...
>>Narrator: Described by
different labels and delivered
in various forms, the concept
is as old as apprenticeships--
to link learning to careers.
>>So what are two ways of
stimulating your heart rate?
>>Narrator: At Bravo Medical
Magnet High School in Los Angeles,
all students are exposed to career
opportunities in the health field.
>>Student: This electrode's going
to be measuring your brainwaves,
so I'm going to put an
electrode on your forehead
and one electrode on your ear.
>>Student: Okay.
>>Narrator: There are also smaller
academies within the school,
like the Engineering
for Health Academy,
in which students move together
through a three-year curriculum
of focused, academic,
and technical study.
>>Teacher: And when it's such a
small amount, we do really need
to make sure that it's exact.
>>Narrator: Bravo forms
partnerships with local businesses
and institutions like the University
of Southern California Medical
Center, which provide internships
and other work-based
learning opportunities.
>>Faizan: I've been testing my
compounds, which are my drugs,
basically trying to
find a cure for cancer.
>>Mark: Education has to
be much more hands on.
We can't continue to just
educate students in silos
and not integrate technologies into-
into medical applications
in this case.
>>Student: So where's
the edit at right now?
>>Narrator: Since academies
generally have a limited number
of slots available, students
develop a sense of community,
and learning becomes personal
because teachers know
each student individually.
>>Shawn: What is this
poster representing
since you're putting it in?
>>Narrator: Shawn Sullivan teaches
a sequence of animation courses
at Sheldon High School in Sacramento.
>>Shawn: Doing an academy
is really important.
It gives a chance for the students
to be around likeminded students.
>>Student: Okay, so we're going to
start off master chart right here
and the narrator introduces the film,
"Ah, the natural selection pet shop."
>>Shawn: What they're really
learning is what they can take
to any job they do as working
with teams, coming up with an idea
and sharing it with others, and
seeing it being finished and created.
>>Student: One, two, three, go.
>>Student: Oh, I just signed
up to see what it was,
green energy technology.
Wonder what it is.
Took the class, love it.
Just going home, telling my
parents, "Look what I learned.
I made biodiesel.
I created a solar bicycle ambulance."
All right.
Act sick. Actually want to continue,
maybe become electrical engineer.
>>Student: Let me see
if the light works.
Check it out.
>>Narrator: According
to recent studies,
academies have higher attendance
and lower dropout rates.
Twice as many high-risk students
complete required core classes
when enrolled in academies, and more
of those students apply to college.
>>Student: Bravo has been great.
This is like the only place that
offers me a chance to work at a lab,
and this experience has helped me.
Yes, it's actually pretty fun.
>>Keith: I chose this academy
because I'm trying to get
into like a computer-based
technological-based career
when I grow up, and so
like this really helps me
with the hands-on problem solving.
>>Teacher: This one's
going a long way.
>>Keith: Yeah.
It just integrates everything in
to where you have to learn how
to work together with
people and things
to get something finished
and accomplished.
>>Teacher: Was a good shot.
Nice, Keith.
All right.
Back to the launch site.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to
Edutopoia dot org.